you might find this hard to believe but
I can be a little childish sometimes
myself yes
you have a gum in your hair right now
noted this is so unfair I've lived in
this building 15 years and then all of a
sudden they decide they're going co-op
with zero warning it seems illegal they
didn't tell you this was happening well
it's possible I missed a letter but I
doubt it oh let's check the mail tab
mail tub nope no no
see it's impossible to find anything in
here it's not my fault this is actually
a cool little bathroom nice clawfit tub
which I will never throw my mail into
again
okay I got your favorite cake blue I'm
not hungry
it's a figure of speech obviously I'll
have some here are two pictures
one is your locker the other is a
garbage dump in the Philippines can you
tell which is which
that one sit down they're both your
locker I should have guessed that it's
good this folder is labeled undies comma
dirty so I won't confuse it with undies
comic clean also who cares about all
these rules I have more felony arrests
than any other detective here you also
have more mice living in your desk than
any other Detective
Algernon
you guys algernon's back get rid of the
mouse and get your act together now
he's grumpy here's the plan we're gonna
catch this perp you're gonna remember
how much you love your job you're gonna
skip that interview and that's a Peralta
guarantee your last parole to guarantee
was that you could dunk a basketball I
never said I couldn't use the ladder for
all to guarantee achieved
the subtext of the guarantee was that
you would be entertained and you were
Gina I know you like champagne with a
drop of pomegranate juice I like to say
it's a Nature's classiest alcohol mixed
with its nastiest fruit and Peralta I
hope this will do it's a can of orange
soda from when some other children
visited it's perfect I suppose we could
look into it yes great let's go right
now no time to lose don't look just run
you're trying to get me out of here
before I see the orange soda you spilled
on the chair aren't you I'm already out
the door it worked you did it fuzzy you
busted them it's time to come home
I'm not sure if I can I've been
undercover so long I've forgotten who I
am I have seen terrible things I haven't
known the touch of a woman in many moons
detective Santiago
don't walk away from me no surprises
from the corner two gunshots shoulder
and chest none of the neighbors heard or
saw anything and what's worse Santiago
struck out with a 92 year old that is
not accurate sir wait you hooked up with
him all right hit the pawn shops and
canvas the neighborhood and while you're
out you can buy yourself a tie oh
actually sir
I'm wearing a tie right now check it out
secret tie
uh adult parties Sergeant I believe
they're called orgies no look five why
are there so many rules I mean next
thing you're gonna say is we can't be
late yeah that's like the first thing I
said uh
hello good sir I'd like your finest
bottle of wine please that will be
sixteen hundred dollars great I'd like
your eight dollarest bottle of wine
please I guess that's your new best
friend now Santiago emphasis on Iago
backstabber I'm surprised you've read
Othello what the hell's a fellow I'm
calling you the parrot from Aladdin I
think I just figured something out I
gotta go aren't you forgetting something
uh
no pay your bill
damn who raised you uh wait where's Jake
well there's a TV card suspiciously in
the middle of the room that ceiling tile
is out of place and he said he was going
to hide somewhere Reckless so I'm
guessing he's up there that's right Amy
I'm in the ceiling unlike you boring old
fogies I found the craziest
story
my bones and ribs broke my phone
pretty irresponsible
yesterday you took the batteries out of
our smoke detector to put in your Big
Mouth Billy Bass you noticed yeah
we're gonna take a trip as soon as we
have time I promise just like you
promised we would see the Bumblebee
movie I didn't promise that I believe
what I said was isn't that a kids movie
yeah and I believe what I said was it's
for teams here's a list of everything
you cannot eat while we're trying to
conceive no more nachos even if they're
in a novelty baseball helmet no whoa
this is serious we adhere to a strict
exercise regimen and sleep schedule also
no more video games because they cause
stress and they raise your heart rate
more stress than being a police officer
Jake I've seen you play Mario Party
Mario cheats I'm just saying what Mario
Jesus stupid game what's up Peralta
Captain called he needs everybody back
there's a lead on the Nightingale
Strangler we're looking for a white male
510 medium build brown hair small scar
on his right cheek
okay his ammo is he finds lonely women
with no friends poisons their food and
then guts him in his van he's pretty
gnarly last scene wearing a salmon shirt
gray Blazer and Witnesses have said he
has trouble fitting lettuce in his mouth
okay where are you apparently has the
world's smallest penis and doesn't know
how to use it hi there I'm Jake Peralta
Amy's boss that's not true what are you
doing here I am here on a date who is
now leaving worth it have a great night
your boss seems really nice he's not my
boss yes I am so you were just borrowing
those cars ask about his bank account
ask about his bank account
you should ask him about his bank
account Captain Santiago broke the glass
so I'm just gonna grab a healthy
breakfast are those gummy bears wrapped
in a food Roll-Up
breakfast burrito but yeah I pity your
dentist ah joke's on you I don't have a
dentist now I have a question for you is
there any way I can borrow four hundred
and thirty thousand dollars why on Earth
do you need that much money I need to
buy my apartment I've been living at my
nana's place since she passed away
because it's rent controlled but now the
building's going Co-op so I have to buy
it I need to secure a loan by the end of
the day uh so should we do a wire
transfer or do you think cash is easier
let's just do cash shouldn't you be
asking somebody else for that kind of
money like a bank yeah I tried that
laughs
[Music]
hey Captain so you found something hey I
like the target
if you can't beat them join them
anyway I think I got something good here
turns out the name Radco is made up but
I was digging through these files one of
which I literally found in a spider web
and it turns out there were a bunch of
references to a Serbian Thug street
names the rat and the butcher he was
known to hang out at a storage unit near
Borum Park which has red soil hence the
muddy red footprint on morgenthau's
counter
that's fine work detective thank you
very much sir Testament to what can be
achieved when you dress appropriately
it's found it out
you know what such fine police work
let's share it with the whole team
Santiago boy of Diaz get
it
serious
work of the fine Master detective Jay
Peralta yeah let's have a hand everyone
[Applause]
that's how we do it in the 99 sir catch
bad guys and look good doing
what's wrong with you never took off the
speedo big mistake it is inside me great
work team
[Music]